So let’s follow our Jersey Square team down
and see what they’ve done for customer
relationships. We’ll it’s really interesting to
remember when they first started. Customer
relationships for then said search ads, social
medium and stadium promotions. And there
was nothing wrong with that. But really
what they discovered is that they were actually
just talking about the customer acquisition
portion, or the get portion of customer
relationships. But we really want teams to
understand, what you can do to keep customers
long-term, and what are you going to do
to grow them in the next couple of years as we.
So we ask you to think about get, keep
and grow. And they did a good job of
getting out of the building and doing that.